hey guys this is Eric I'm back for
another video on answering people's
questions
I've yet to finalize a name for the
series I'm thinking about starting a
hashtag like hashtag ask I am Rosen and
then have people answer questions via
Twitter but if anyone has other
suggestions just let me know in the
comments for this video I want to
address a question that was left in the
YouTube comments from someone named
Heflin and I'll bring up the question
here it's a little bit long I'm not
gonna read the whole thing but
essentially he mentioned okay he
mentioned my DVD on the London which is
distributed through HS and there's a
separate video on HS is channel where I
give a quick introduction to the course
I can leave a link in the description if
people want to check that out but
essentially he's asking about how to
meet C 5 on move one if if White's
playing d4 and if you're a London player
and what I would recommend and he went
on kind of a ramble here not to say that
rambling is bad or anything but he maybe
had this inner conflict of whether to
respond with c3 or respond with d5 and
I'm more than happy to to give some
suggestions and and show what I would
play maybe share some secrets so let's
go ahead and switch over to the board
let's get to this position with d4 c5 I
would say there's two main options for
whites which I'll actually go through
both of them if you're a London player
this is a one thing it's it's hard to
play the London against because the
problem is with a move like c3 it's
first of all allowing like this
immediate trade it could actually just
transpose to like an exchange Slav or
lines where like black might have an
early Queen b6 which could be annoying
so I don't recommend playing c3 let me
start with recommending this is actually
my top recommendation is not to play d5
but to take on c5
I think this is by far the trickiest
line that white can play and it looks
somewhat wrong at first it looks weird
giving away a center pawn and because in
many cases but I can easily win the pawn
back but there's a very specific line
that if black walks into there is
there's a few different ways like can
reach a very pleasant position so let's
say black plays e6 here which I believe
is the most common move most logical
move just finding they should take c5
now white won't go ahead and hold onto
the pawn but white will just develop
with Knight c3 let's say black takes
upon and now the main idea is to play 94
hitting the bishop but also hitting this
this g6 square and if black is
unprepared this can pose some early
problems for black now I know this is
not a traditional London setup you just
sometimes it's a matter of reacting to
what the ponen is doing but in this case
there's two main targets and now white
has to or black has to figure out how to
save the bishop and how to cover d6 and
it's not so simple for black if we
imagine black plays perhaps a normal
move like Bishop e7 white is more than
happy to hop into d6
I've had many online blitz and bullet
games where ponen takes I take back and
why it's already having a very pleasant
position to bishops Queen on d6 is quite
annoying white is ready to reinforce
this with Bishop f4 and casting Queen
side so I've I've had pretty good
success from this position as White's
going back if Bishop e7 isn't played
there's another move which actually
looks interesting for black and it's
it's certainly a playable move which is
d5 allowing light to capture the bishop
but then responding with Queen a5 check
double attack winning back the minor
piece now the thing about this line is
White has a nice idea that after c3
Queen takes e5 white can play really
nice
a positional move Pawnee for and this
isn't a sacrifice given that if Pont a
key for then queen g4 and essentially
whatever happens from here the position
is going to open up
and because White has the two bishops
and whites about to get some initiative
if this Queen g4 line happens white will
inevitably have some advantage going
forward into the middle game if black
doesn't take on e4 and black plays some
other move like Knight of six white is
also happy to consider a move like a
five I'm checking some opening reference
here because I remember playing a game
not too long ago where my opponent
played 97 I played Knight f3 and
something like this happened knight c6
Bishop f4 this is very much resembling a
French structure where if flack ends up
castling and white can play Bishop to d3
there's already ideas of some kind of
Greek gifts like Bishop take h7 and
Knight g5 so black has to be careful
entering these positions where White has
this pawn on e5 and just to demonstrate
the other line real quick if if D take
e4 queen g4 I mean white is uh is happy
to win back upon either the e4 or g7
pawn is falling and it will lead to a
position where both bishops will come in
naturally I've included a game here that
I found in the Masters database which i
think is a good demonstration of how
play can continue I'm not going to go
through it in this video but if people
want to take a look you can find it here
I'll of course share the study link in
the video description and you can click
the citation here if you want to see
that full game between two names I'm not
gonna even try and pronounce but okay
going back to the the line I think think
in many cases black will be unprepared
for this and many cases while you will
have a slight advantage now I will go
ahead and show the best response for
black if if white were to play this line
and this might be useful for the black
players who might play c5 on move one
against d4 the best move for black here
is to play Knight f6 using the same idea
with Queen a5 check as after Knight
takes e5 Queen a5 c3 Queen takes e5 the
main difference here is white doesn't
have this powerful explosive efore move
and it's a bit more positional in nature
and white does have the bishop pair of a
black has a better pawn center so this
is about equal I mean it's not it's not
bad for a why that's not bad for a black
it's playable for both sides this is the
type of position better player will
probably win but it's very playable for
whites and I think it's it's worth
perhaps playing this position if if
there's so much potential in other lines
too to have these these traps if white
we're wanting to continue from this
position I recommend feeding kettering
the light squared bishop and you can
enter some line like this I was doing
some computer analysis earlier and okay
this is a thick go to setup for whites
and if black does go for this 'if I've
move then white actually has a nice move
Bishop to g5 just to apply a lot of
pressure in the center craft running to
take and double the pawns and if black
goes for a move like Knight e4 counter
attacking the bishop and removing then
the Knights then I can respond with
Bishop e3 and okay there's many ways
these lines can branch out but I think
if if white gets to this position it's
very playable so that's kind of its kind
of D takes e5 in a nutshell going back
from or going back to this position I
think if you take on c5 it's likely lack
black will play e6 and then knowing this
Knight c3 94 idea should offer some
interesting chances for whites now I did
say I wanted to cover both options going
back to this position and I do want to
talk a little bit about d5 because it's
probably the most principled move and
objectively it's it's the best move I
don't think there's too much argument
that can be made I mean at a high level
c5 is not popular
on move one because of d5 because of the
fact that black concedes a lot of space
from very early on now this line and
especially if black plays a v next which
is a kind of the move that I think Chet
was questioning this does prevent light
from playing the London because white
can no longer develop the Bishop to f4
and it doesn't really make sense to take
on passant and give away your very nice
space grabbing pawn on d5 so I think
it's if you're looking to go into the
sign that's a matter of understanding
how to play the structure for whites and
I'm gonna keep this relatively simple
and just show kind of a basic set up how
white should continue developments I
recommend playing efore I also recommend
on holding off of playing c4 and we'll
see why this is relevant but you don't
want to play c4 too early because in
many cases you want your light squared
bishop to come to b5 in some cases
you're happy to trade off the light
square bishop because you're centered
pawns are on my squares and this is
usually your bad bishop so the bishop
would like to come to c5 and normally
the Knights will develop in front of
your C pawn to c3 and some cases later
on white is happy to bring the knight to
f3 and then transfer it to c4 and also
combine that with with a 4 to discourage
black from playing d5 so I know there's
a lot of arrows here but this is kind of
a general summary even though it's so
early in the game sometimes want to
start thinking about where the pieces
are optimized going forward into the
middle game so let's go forward here
I've included a game between version of
Cobian pretty well known lecture for the
st. Louis chess club YouTube channel he
had a nice victory over the late Emory
Tate's back in 2004 and a Cobian used
the set up with Knight c3 and then
Bishop to b5 check and in that game tape
played Knight to d7
and I'll go ahead and show here let's
just switch back to the study view that
if people want to look at this game
further you can go into this link
and this will open up in a new tab and
then you can see the full game and maybe
I'll go ahead and give some brief
commentary on this game just show what
happened
so after 97 ok 9 f3 now I mentioned
earlier that sometimes why this happy
trading off LightSquared Bishop in this
case white keeps the lights for a bishop
plays Bishop to d3 I think this is also
very reasonable because black is so
restricted on space like with all these
minor pieces still on the board there's
not too many squares to work with and
white is happy to to keep all the minor
pieces on the board this is very general
rule in chess when you when you have
more space you should avoid trade so
minor pieces of course there's
exceptions and I'm not going to get into
that too deeply but just something to
keep in mind black played h6 castling
Bishop g5 and then pawn a four useful
move preventing b5 actually a bit
curious if that plays b5 right away what
a Cobian had in mind this might be
something to ask engine I'm pretty sure
84 could be a strong move
given that b5 is now a target and this
might provoke black to overextend like
if black plays b4 then white can play 92
and now there's a very nice see for
square like white has ideas of 90 to 94
maybe some future f4 also if black plays
c4 here oops
after after a fourth black plays c4 then
the bishop can drop back to e2 and again
black is a bit overextended like the b5
pawn is still attacked okay if b4 then
like to be won and I think it's white
who's getting the last laugh given that
this pawn is now hanging and severely
weak so maybe that's why a Cobian
allowed b5 from from early on so Bishop
g5 was played a 4 ok preventing b5
grabbing more space the bishops do get
traded
and after 97 my
t-too we see this very typical maneuver
an idea of bringing the night to d2 of
course is to get the C 4 square also to
someday play a5 and fix these pawns and
also create a weakness on b6 and other
idea is to play f4 just expand on the
kingside open up open on that file and
maybe get some kingside play as well so
very multi-purpose move Knight d2 Knight
G 694 Knight b6 and now 93 so why the
voids the train leaves in like kind of
awkward on v6 9 f4 is played a5 kicking
the Knights 97 g3 kicking other knights
White's probably happy here if a bishop
gets traded off then I think this is a
nice structure to play with f4 coming at
some point so things got a bit crazy
here after Knight h3 check King g2 and
then Knight f6 on the light stayed on h3
and then a KO being went for Knight f5
or has been fine gold would say knife f5
don't sue me for copyrights but this is
a nice a nice little obstruction of the
bishop defending the Knights and now
this Knight is kind of left a bit
stranded and Tate had a reputation of
being a very aggressive player and
instead of retreating the Knights
probably a normal person he played g6
with a counter-attack and then a Cobian
took on h3 which looks somewhat risky
and after GTA got 5 ETA got five White's
up a pawn but the Kings on h3 so it's a
very kind of confusing position
eventually what happened is black one
the pawn back and then the King just ran
back to safety she went back even
further to g1 to avoid Bishop h3 check
and from this point forward white just
had a pleasant position even though it
seems like black got some initiative and
was able to trade and maybe free up the
pieces White's position is still
Pleasant for a few reasons I mean the c4
pawn is quite weak given that
five can't be played due to on passant
and it's currently attacked and rook-a
for ism on the horizon and also Bach no
longer has this jihad
so if black wants to Castle kingside I
mean the King's not going to be safe on
that part of the board and in fact
there's not too many safe places on the
board for the black King so let's see
what happened we see f4 is played to
open up the center given that blacks
King is still in the center and this is
just a very thematic idea efore played
Queen III it's now both of these pawns
are target's rook c5 Knight a4 nice
positional move and then after Knight b6
I think this is a big turning point
where white wins the Queen for four rook
and migrant piece after rook take a1
they eventually get to this position
with white just having a substantial
advantage and I'm not going to go any
further from here but the main point of
this was to show how okay from early on
the position is nice to play for white I
think if you know the setup and this is
a common practice like if you don't know
perhaps what to do a against this urn
opening it's good to see a game of a
strong Grandmaster and see how they beat
another strong player and then try and
replicates at least how they they place
their pieces so I hope that helped if I
go back to the study here I've included
the question in the study I turn off the
Explorer we can scroll up here and see
the full question I hope I have
addressed most of the points I hope this
is of some value to two people if you
guys have any follow-up questions just
let me know and I'll be happy to answer
and hopeful have the time and energy to
do more videos like this so with that I
will see everyone in the next video
thanks for watching